thank you
[Music]
all right you guys know about the
Batgirl movie that got canceled right 90
million dollar movie Michelle did
Batgirl yeah oh yeah yeah yeah it got it
got totally shelved so what happened is
they're saying it was like a change in
uh management so now they don't want to
spend the money on did they spend like
90 million or something wait they spent
it cutting it yeah oh they just had a
budget I think that was the budget I
don't know if that means it was all no
that was the budget but I think they
spent a bunch of it they had already
shot like a bunch of it yeah who was
supposed to be Batgirl
all I know is that's Ian's girlfriend
what's her name um Ian's girlfriend he's
with his girlfriend yeah
um I don't even know they were making a
Batgirl movie yeah see that's why they
flushed it that's why they canned it I
mean the whole concept sounds lame but
is she hot though
she's beautiful but I mean they usually
are is it Leslie Grace yes Leslie Grace
because Batgirl sounds boring
what what did she like about that girl
it just doesn't seem like she's gonna
[ __ ] solve any crime
he's like that's her that's Lizzie Grace
by the way oh she is beautiful she's hot
yeah I forgot Batgirl like what the
what's her background like I can't
remember anybody I thought it was Batman
and Catwoman like I thought yeah I
thought it was uh I thought it was
commissioner Gordon's like daughter or
some [ __ ] right it's really it is in
some iterations yeah does she like help
steam Batman's cape or something or what
else would you do what else would you do
she just makes dinner for Batman what
else would Batgirl do dude
Alfred's supposed to do all that [ __ ] so
for me I'm just like what else did I
remember Alfred's uh gay is he
oh
according to the best gaydar in cinema
all right so what happened is they they
shelved it and the directors they're
like this is really what they did they
were like desperate to at least get some
footage of it they they rushed to the
server once they you know got the news
and the dude one director says the other
yo get your uh mobile out and just film
the [ __ ] screen like right now so
then they go to the server online to try
to get access to it they've discovered
they've been blocked out of the files so
they will never ever see this movie ever
again yeah that's such a wait who got
blocked out the directors of the film
but this basically happened because uh
during that whole time where DC had to
like revamp everything they like let uh
their former DC like uh I guess head for
Warner Brothers or whoever the [ __ ] does
it uh got let go or something like that
and then a new director or or the
overall director of who runs all DC
stuff uh no Warner Brothers is it Warner
Brothers because all the movies been
sucking assets
they put together like they want to put
together a 10 you're planned because
they've been just [ __ ] things out
randomly and now they're like okay we
gotta model the way that like Kevin
feige modeled for MCU they like we
should plan this all out guys that's a
good idea you know we did the Justice
League and then we re-released in black
and white you know we should do Suicide
Squad [ __ ] Aquaman everything sucks out
dude the second the new Suicide Squad
was fired yeah the second Suicide Squad
but hey John Cena's show whatever that
is that show is [ __ ] hella funny oh
it's good the villains that they do on
DC are fun like the Harley Quinn movies
I mean Joker Jared Leto horrible because
DC always had a darker vibe yeah and
they should stick to it that's what I
mean Batgirl sounds boring but I've had
Joker girl that have been tight they do
have Joker girls
and it was tight Bart's right yeah but
you want a separate like Joker gold
character played by Amy Schumer or just
she steals everyone's jokes
she acts as a waitress I just wanted him
to say yes before hearing what I said
but I mean between I think now like for
example they've already got so many
[ __ ] up things right there's the Ezra
Miller flash [ __ ] that's going on dude
so what happened with that guy great
publicity there yeah he fought somebody
in Hawaii he like choked a girl like uh
he like pushed a chick up against the
wall everywhere he goes he's doing he's
[ __ ] up so it's multiple times
multiple times and now there's like a
missing persons thing with his like weed
farm or some [ __ ] no way dude how is he
not arrested and he just and he just
came out finally with like some sort of
apology that's like uh you know for my
behavior I know that blah blah blah but
I'm I'm putting in the work now in order
to yada yada yada so there's that then
then you got Black Adam which like uh
blackened with the rock he's like he's
like I'm like redoing the entire you
know the rock just like you do with Fast
and Furious he comes he comes into a
franchise that he didn't build himself
but he's like I built this thing by
myself right which I love him for it so
so there's nothing but random [ __ ] well
we got the [ __ ] Amber Heard nonsense
where she had to get cut from like
Aquaman 2 and stuff so like their whole
DC
well they did do Joker right with
Joaquin Phoenix they did the second one
yeah yeah they're doing this do they
still own Joker and Batman do they still
own the IP for all that yeah yeah
because that's taiwaki in Phoenix hell
yeah he [ __ ] crushed it that's one of
my favorites that restored my faith a
little in DC and I was like oh they got
it down and then they're just dropping
the ball constantly who do you know who
directed The Joker uh Rick Moranis but
the the new one is gonna have Lady Gaga
on it too yeah which I'm high for
because she plays Harley Quinn
she crushed it in House of Gucci yeah
she's dope in general she's like she's
really really so the thing that sucks is
that while some people believe they're
like release the movie like just put it
out yeah who cares the director said
that even if that would happen it would
be absolutely impossible because they're
not even done shooting it they didn't do
any of the VFX there's several scenes
missing that they never even got to
shoot so they said if that's ever going
to be a reality they would have to be
allocated that budget in the future get
everybody back together and then finish
the scenes which they [ __ ] up with on
the Snyder one already exactly yeah what
do you mean the Snyder one though that's
why they released a whole nother one
right yeah so well first again correct
me if I'm wrong but the first one came
out or when it was about to come out
Snyder had to like balance because his
like daughter committed suicide or died
or something like that so you had to
leave the project it got finished up
didn't happen the right way everybody
for a long time was like release the
Snyder cut release the Snyder cut right
so he comes back Warner Brothers gives
him like 100 million more dollars or
some [ __ ] put together this four hour
like epic thing for the HBO Max it was
cool though it was dope but it didn't
mirror it and or hit the need for like a
hundred million dollar plus budget when
I saw the second well I saw the Snyder
cut and I watched it in like eight parts
throughout like three months but I I I
was like I don't see the difference
between this one and the first one it's
very different if you watch it in one
day
it's really different you probably don't
remember so many things I don't think
you're right on this okay I didn't watch
the first one I only watched the Snyder
good yeah so I thought it was pretty
cool
the first one is very not as good yeah
so they said they were comparing it to
that and they were like oh you know
people kind of hope it could be
something like that the two directors
they don't think even that has a chance
it's because they just know how much is
left to do and in the the kind of nature
of this which was rug pulled from them
they're like
it's not gonna happen why would they rug
pull that if they're because I heard
they were gonna just put it on streaming
anyway they were gonna put it straight
to HBO Max yeah but I mean it's all good
just focus on the Joker too and they're
just it's just that they reallocated the
money that was supposed to go that
direction maybe they're just like I'm
I'm sick of turning out [ __ ] this is
all Ezra Miller's fault or it might be
the person who originally green lit that
who's maybe no longer there and the new
management is like yeah [ __ ] whatever
that guy decisions were because he's the
reason why the shit's burning down I can
totally understand from that point of
view though like if I were for example
to come back in and it's like all right
look we got to redo everything with DC
you know what I mean then like you don't
start on Batgirl that's right
yeah you start on K-PAX too okay packs
baby make a Nightwing movie it should be
all villains focus on uh Lex Luthor dude
have you seen these have you seen the
suicide squad
uh is the one Will Smith yeah not that
one though cause that was horrible even
that one wait Will Smith is not in the
Snyder cup no no no in the uh the first
uh suicide suicide the second Suicide
Squad
it's very you should watch it because
James Gunn did it right that's a little
that's why because the first one was so
bad I didn't watch the second one watch
the second one
the second one I'm not gonna hype it up
too much but it was like it was really
fun and I I returned and you gotta
remember the second one is not a sequel
the second one happened because the
first one was so bad they redid it
completely
yeah the Margot Robbie bags of Harley
Quinn because she did a good job
everybody else said recast yeah oh
it's a fun movie like it's a fun movie
to watch it was so good they they did
the spin-off with John Cena as
Peacemaker CCP head of the CCP
Peacemaker is really good
yeah now he is yeah he's the white
representative he also he's also like
fluent in Mandarin yeah it's very true
that I feel like I feel like at least
with new management and everything going
on with DC they kind of know how hard it
is to they have to win people over again
yeah because people are like afraid of
it now they need to scrap everything
that they're planning doing regardless
what the [ __ ] it is take all that money
AKA like a billion dollars be like
Christopher Nolan come here and do
everything for 10 years
why why make seven more Batmans with
seven different people I don't get it
yeah coach Pat Riley there while you're
so much so much different like every guy
from moneyballing characters yeah yeah
get the guy from Moneyball dude and how
come they haven't had a really good
Superman in a minute well to be fair
actually I think out of the entire uh DC
all that Superman might have been the
best uh not better than Dark Knight
right no that's Christopher Nolan's
version the Superman that's comparable
to the rest of the DC stuff with Justice
League is a Ben Affleck Batman yeah oh
you know what I'm saying like Ben
Affleck worked with Henry Cavill in like
that stuff and like Superman Batman
versus Superman or whatever but Superman
never worked with Christopher Nolan's
Batman no no it was ever or Christopher
Nolan no there was no Dark Superman yeah
that's what I'm saying is like there was
an ERA where Superman was so sick
because we were all younger and then
they didn't this darks uh Batman was
never redone like the way that they did
Joker and all that stuff that they never
touched Superman I did enjoy Henry
Cavill though as Superman I think that
was great casting yeah he's a good
Superman
he looks like him it was all right but I
think it was I think it was it would
think I think it was good compared to
aka Superman or Man of Steel or
whichever one it was I think that was
still better than Wonder Woman Wonder
Woman was pretty good
trash bro
one woman two was terrible I like
wondering Wonder Woman one was pretty
good I'll give that to that I fell
asleep it was definitely better than
Batman vs Superman's better than Justice
League it was better than Aquaman it was
you know what I mean they should do
small build that's what they do they
redo small people get Christian crook
yeah dude where's the [ __ ] high
school but like that that way Superman
would be cool though like they they
start him from high school and then like
build them up I think that'd be cool
because we all get the [ __ ] you know
he walks on the phone booth put the
glasses on there's no photos he's gonna
be like oh [ __ ]
it's just an hour and a half of that
yeah there's a [ __ ] crime did
somebody call someone
he's coming I swear he's coming he's on
his way and he gets one of those [ __ ]
camping Porta-Potty [ __ ] that he sets up
like oh [ __ ] and he changes it and he
[ __ ] opens it goes to a [ __ ] uh a
Little Tokyo photo booth
he just starts using fun of Asian photo
booths Carnival photo boots
will say for everybody who's about to
watch uh wakanda forever and thinks
Neymar is a biter of Aquaman remember
Neymar came out before
but he's equally as lame yeah yeah
laymore yeah that's stupid